um figures that are released immediately
are very often revised so the previous
quarter's figure showed a contraction
was then revised to show economic growth
so be very careful about how you
interpret figures immediately after
their release okay so we shouldn't take
too much notice of that it's a small
amount of a very large economy but these
figures are notorious for being revised
afterwards
funds at risk no our Pension funds
aren't at risk
um some Pension funds have taken some
high risk Investments
um Andrew Bailey um said that um
in three days time Friday
um Pension funds uh that he has been
trying to support by the bank of England
he will withdraw the emergency help for
that
How concerned are you by by that
language
um the question is not not many fold
really but first of all there's the
issue of the relatively high risk
Investments that some Pension funds have
made that they were gearing on their
guilt Holdings and the problem with
gearing is that when values change if
they change sharply which has been a
phenomenon with guilds because of the
change in interest rates so the
underlying base rate has gone up
significantly in this country and
globally and now if you've seen long
rates move out
um and that's been happening here as
elsewhere that's had an effect on
Pension funds there's also also
valuation issue with long-term guilds
many Pension funds will be holding them
for their full duration we'll be
expecting to get them redeemed at the
end of 30 years but maybe an obligation
to mark them to Market if they're
marking them to Market they may find
that they have actually a false
valuation on investment that's intended
to be held to maturity I'm sure that my
uh viewers my audience got almost all of
that but the bottom line is that Andrew
Bailey thought it was um in concerning
enough to offer emergency help that will
be withdrawn he says on Friday I'm
saying to you how concerned should we be
that the governor of the bank of England
and these very important job has said
come Friday they're on the road
well the bank of England is obviously
operationally independent and that's
quite right and the governor will make
decisions in accordance with the markets
but the bank of England does have a
responsibility and has had a
responsibility for a very long time to
ensure the orderly functioning markets
and therefore it intervenes from time to
time when there are unexpected events
when does it become the government's
problem
well the government of the bank of
England worked very closely together
within the confines of the independence
of the bank of England
that the bank of England is quite
rightly operationally independent and
you will remember all the arguments over
this about why it was better to have an
independent interest rates better
um but nonetheless economic decision
making involves both the bank of England
and the government so the two the two
work together in the confines of
independence of the bank but you don't
think it's a problem with them with the
pensions and the bank of England does no
the bank of England has made its
position clear that it's been helping
because of a specific problem what I was
answering was whether there is a
systemic problem in Pension funds which
that doesn't seem to be are there
problems with some Pension funds that
have taken risky Investments which the
bank of England is helping with yes
these are two separate questions should
they continue with the help post Friday
I shouldn't intervene in matters where
the bank of England operates into
independently okay well I'm reading the
Ft this morning which is suggesting that
privately the bank of England is saying
that it will support Beyond Friday
um is that the governor
potentially stoking up anxiety
unnecessarily you must interview the
governor it'd be quiet look I'm a
government Minister the bank of England
is independent I think the bank of
England Independence is fundamental to
the stability of the UK economy and I
think government ministers there have no
business
um wading in on what the bank of England
is is doing the banking has Independence
yeah I understand that but if the bank
of England is saying the Andrew Bailey
is saying one thing in public and one
thing in private and that is impacting
the markets that's impacting our economy
which is impacting the government you
must interview Mr Bailey what's your
view no I'm not going to criticize the
bank of England uh or the governor that
it not for me to speculate on what the
bank of England is doing it isn't yes of
course I've Got Confidence in the
government bank I mean
it is so important that we have an
independent bank of England with a
respected Governor Andrew Bailey is a
respected governor and the bank of
England's Independence is operating as
its should he must make the decisions in
relation to Market support and for
ministers to interfere would be
undermining the Independence Bank of
England bringing much confidence in the
government it says the situation with
the economy is Way Beyond anything the
bank has stress tested for well the bank
of England stress test should be there
to ensure the bank of England is ready
for whatever happens within the economy
but you shouldn't be surprised by some
of the moves markets do move quickly and
we have had the lowest level of interest
rates in history not just in decades not
just since
1970 or any of those figures but in the
whole of our economic history we have
had consistently the lowest rates now
that was always going to change at some
time
and when it changes it changes on the
long rate more than it does on the short
rate usually for obvious reasons you
should have changed sooner but interest
rates are set independently by the bank
of England but they're also set by the
markets so the markets determine when
long rates move rather than it being set
by the banking opinion you're a very
successful businessman you know a lot
about the markets as you've already
Illustrated do you think interest rates
should have gone up sooner again the
bank of England is independent so I'm
going to keep my private views private
um
it certainly had an impact on people's
mortgages hasn't it um what impact has
it had on your mortgage but I've never
thought that my personal financial
circumstances we could discuss yours as
well mortgage has gone up what about
yours mortgage rates have gone up for
everybody who has a mortgage and I have
a mortgage but my personal financial
circumstances I don't think of um ones
to draw
I did and I told you and I've answered
and we've both had mortgages that have
gone up and so as your mortgage gone up
no
any floating rate mortgages have gone up
has yours Yes mine has gone up okay
um do you think
benefits should go up in line with
inflation but we haven't yet had the
inflation figure on which benefits will
be said so that is something that will
be decided once the figure is available
well well we know that you can predict
these things very successfully
um we're also have the help of many
other very clever people who are saying
that inflation would go up about 10
percent well you you say those wages
will go up about 5.2 something like that
you say You can predict these things
actually most predictions most economic
forecasts uh turn out to be inaccurate
rather than spot on say one's got to be
careful about forecast as I was saying
earlier with the GDP figure inflation is
going to get more than wages isn't it
lots of figures that come out get
revised later but I think the broad
Point you're making that inflation will
rise more than wages this year is
accurate and to that end should benefits
go up in line with inflation there's a
process for making this decision this
decision will be made once the figures
come out a stature instrument has to be
laid in November
um to put through the increase that will
be done in the normal away this is
completely routine governmental decision
making its decision made by this extra
safe working pensions that will be made
in the normal way yeah but what's your
opinion
my opinion is government policy I'm not
sitting here as a commentator for a
journal or a back bench MP I'm sitting
as a member of the government where
there is a decision-making process the
discussions on how things should be
managed are ones that need to take place
in private before a government policy is
announced for which we are then
accountable to Parliament I think to
discuss I think this and he thinks that
and she thinks the other is not a good
way of making government policy no but
surely given the situation that many
people are finding themselves in at the
moment and relying on benefits they need
to be reassured that they will get
benefits increased in line with
inflation well quite a number of
benefits will increase in line with
inflation by law anyway so there's a
subset of benefits where a decision will
be made and the triple lock for
pensioners will remain
in
full state that that will be applied
I spoke to the Deputy Prime Minister
yesterday she said that the economy is
in a good state do you think it is
well I think the economy has some good
points and some areas of difficulty so
you were reporting that the employment
Market remains very strong with
vacancies being lower than the
sorry vacancies being higher than the a
number of people unemployed but there is
a problem with inflation and the
difficulty with inflation is that to
deal with inflation monetary policy has
to tighten and tightly monetary policy
leads to higher mortgages and higher
rates of interest for businesses and
that is never easy it would be wrong
with me to pretend that that is easy so
it's not in a good State there are bits
fit that are in the good state so as I
said employment which is fundamental to
people because employment is the Far and
Away best route out of poverty is in a
very strong state but inflation is not
and that is creating problems yeah okay
um but we go back to what Andrew Bailey
was saying and he says the economy is
Way Beyond anything the bank has Tres
tested for so you know he doesn't think
it's in a particularly good state does
he well he's responsible for monetary
policy and the bank has been putting
interest rates up
um as a consequence of of inflation the
bank of England stress tests are matters
for the bank of England
prime minister as well yesterday about
proposed change to the affordable houses
Target
um she wasn't aware that there was a
proposed change are you aware of it
um I'm aware that there is a discussion
but I'm not aware of the decision having
been made should we look at potentially
not having as many affordable houses for
people to live in I I think it misses
the dynamism of the market that what
matters is the total housing stock
because people move and therefore you
increase the total that's right but by
increasing the total housing stock you
find that houses at other parts of the
market become affordable and therefore
you create a dynamic system I think the
idea that there are houses that are
affordable and houses that are
unaffordable it's not necessarily the
right way of looking at it you've got to
say affordable for whom and under what
circumstances and then this question not
affordable housing but social housing
and what provision are you making there
so I I think there's a two great a
tendency to look at the housing market
as if it's static when it's Dynamic and
that leads to potentially discussing
issues that don't fundamentally change
where people live which is what really
matters I suppose people who are not
earning a particularly High salaries
like nurses would be looking for their
first starter home and affordable
housing to them would be very different
to potentially affordable housing for me
yesterday to raise coffee so there's no
more money to pay nurses a pay increase
and as a result they are not as a result
of what she said but they want more
money and they're going to go on strike
for the first time in more than 100
years
um the pay round this year has already
started being difficult and we're aware
of that that's an obvious concomitant of
inflation that when inflation rise is
then people understandably ask for high
wages but those are not necessarily
affordable and the issue here is how do
you deal with the inflationary problem
that is mainly the monetary policy of
the bank of England but that if you
raise wages fully in line with inflation
you get into the issue of wage push
inflation and continue the inflation
maybe or may well be the case and I'm
sure it is but you know if you can't
afford to feed your kids you want more
money don't you ultimately the taxpayer
has limited resources and we have to
live within our means so how much is
available for public services depends on
economic growth which by the
government's policy is pushing for
economic growth and actually the IMF
yesterday predicted that following the
fiscal statement there would be more
great next year than it had previously
forecast if there's more growth then
there's more tax revenues then there's
more money for everybody involved
those that just two years ago we were
standing our doorsteps clapping for well
the the wage around this year as part of
a negotiation that negotiation will
continue but the taxpayer has limited
money everything that is done by
government has to be funded by taxpayers
either this year or in future if it's
done through borrowing there's not an
unlimited amount of money and
governments always have to work within
that
what should we do about the coronation
how much should we spend on the
Carnation next year
well I don't have a specific figure for
how much
um we don't have coronations very often
uh I think the key to the coronation
actually is that it's a religious
ceremony it is effectively a Sacrament
the last anointed Monarch uh in Europe
um other arguably than the pope with a
ceremony that dates back to Anglo-Saxon
times I think I I think it was
um uh Dunstan Saint Dunstan of
Glastonbury who really devised the
coronation
um no because the costings are entirely
different that comes from the public
person what one is a small one-off
amount in the context of government
expenditure
pay rates are billions of pounds
nobody's talking about a coronation that
will cost billions of Parts how much
should it cost to put a precise figure
on it uh is not not for me to do if it
was to be comparable with the pre
previous one it would be something like
46 million quid that's what it equates
to now from 1953 costs well it depends
how you account for it
um uh I hope we see
um a coronation that is sufficiently
dignified for our Sovereign this is a
one-off course the last one
um was for coronation for a reign of 70
years so this is not something that
happens often it needs to be done
properly and it's completely irrelevant
to pay rates because 46 million pounds
would not buy you an increase in pay for
people employed in the public service of
any amount at all as you know it's
always a pleasure thank you very much
yes thank you very much indeed